so we've been given a new look in the
form of images and footage for love and
thunder so let's break it down so we see
an extended shot of mighty 4 catching
four's hammer where she then says
obviously this is her greeting for in
the next shot we see thor and mighty 4
both jumping into action obviously
something has gathered their attention
and they have gone to investigate it's
hard to know what exactly this is
because there isn't much context here
and then the next shot we have mighty
for catching the hammer once again and i
gotta say i'm really digging her look
here the outfit design for her character
is really good in my opinion and to end
off the new footage of mighty 4 and 4 we
have both of them turning around to look
at something possibly this is them
turning around to look at each other or
possibly something completely different
and to end off all the new footage we
have a new shot of gor the god butcher
here and it's a new shot of him with his
sword where he holds it up in the air
and goes to swing possibly here swinging
at someone or he's just training and
using the sword and i gotta say i like
how they're not showing too much of his
character because i wouldn't experience
it firsthand in the cinema now to the
new images that have been released we
have two new images here of valkyrie the
first image she is on her horse here
which i believe is the pegasus and
judging by the background it seems to be
a similar location where we saw four and
mighty fall fighting in the previous
footage and before we get to the new
valkyrie picture we have a new one of
four here and it looks like it's in the
same background as valkyries and so i'm
guessing this is from the same scene the
next picture of valkyrie she seems to be
in a bar of some kind surrounded by
arcol so this is very fitting for a
character i must say and to end off the
new images we have one more image of
four here and this is just a different
shot of what we have seen previously
from footage and in this image he is
ready for battle anyway that sums up
most of the new footage and images if
you did enjoy this video please leave a
like on this video subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching guys